coming up on Star Talk we're exploring
the future of Life award who gets it
people who had something to do with the
preservation of
civilization and most recently it was
given to storytellers the writers
producers directors of the 1980s film
war games and the day after we're going
to find out why they are celebrated now
in the 40th anniversary of the
appearance of those films and
what that had to say for the
preservation of
Life Society and civilization as we know
it coming up on Star
[Music]
Talk this is Star Talk Neil degrass
Tyson here you're a personal
astrophysicist and of course I got Chuck
nice with me Chuck hey Neil and you know
we're going to talk about today the
future of Life award oh wow I would
think that just getting to go into the
future is an award
oh an award or reward for for a life
hard earned uh let's let's find out more
about this and bring in our two guests
first Larry Lasker Larry welcome thank
you ni yeah you you are a
2023 recipient co-recipient of the
future of Life award you're screenwriter
producer uh I know some of your work you
writer of war games that was that was an
important movie back in the 80s we'll
get we'll get back to that we also have
with us Walter Parks Walter welcome to
Star Talk hi Neil nice to be here
co-writer of War games with Larry that's
just my luck we happen to be on the same
podcast okay and co-recipient of the
2023 future of Life award also a
producer screenwriter uh media executive
more recently co-founder of Dreamscape
learn and this is immersive uh virtual
reality education but also uh the two of
you produced
Awakenings uh I I remember that film
explicitly that received three Oscar
nominations and co-wrote the film
sneakers I remember that had that had
Sydney portier in it I remember that
movie so let's go back in time now uh
2023 was the 40th anniversary of War
Games Matthew brck uh remind me was that
before or after Ferris Bueller's Day Off
I think it was before is that right
right before yeah just before Ferris
bu's day off uh and United Artist
Sherwood Productions and who else was in
that uh we had John Wood Dabney Coleman
Alie CI oh yes of course the the the the
girlfriend Ali shidi and Bary Corbin I
do not he was in that he was the General
yes and he plays that role well because
he reprised something like that in that
long running series um a Northern
Exposure he was a he was aaut military
vet he improvised the line God damn it
I'd piss on a spark plug up I thought it
would do any
good just came up with that on the
set also
Larry if I remember correctly uh he was
based on the actual commander of NORAD
who met who we met y yeah and we named
this one uh this
character and wasn't it General hardener
who said I sleep well at night knowing
I'm in charge yes that's a funny line
well that's what you want in a
general I guess so in a weird sort ofed
way I was gonna say i' I'd sleep better
if I heard that from his actual
soldiers wait wait so guys just remind
us all 1983 we are still in the Cold War
so this is the landscape on which this
movie arrives and it's not just
grown-ups doing their grown-up things it
involves kids and so I thought that was
a brilliant juxtaposition because
they're the Next Generation and how does
it affect them how are they thinking
about the problem just remind us of the
climate the polit geopolitical climate
and then tell us what was the thinking
behind this film I'll tell you as is
become appropriate for a show that's
posted by a uh a
physicist one of the two pillars of that
this really was another physicist um
Larry had been particularly interested
in Stephen Hawking I saw a documentary
on TV about Stephen Hawking and the idea
that he could figure out the unified
field Theory but because of his
condition he wouldn't be able to
communicate it I found a fascinating
existential dilemma and it's suggested
that he needed someone to pass on his
knowledge to a kid who could understand
him and that character became the
character in war
games uh a a juval delinquent type whose
problem was that he was too smart for
his environment quite unbeknownst I had
come across a book about
a a middle class family I think in
Kansas who had a child that turned out
to be a super genius and about what what
the travails of what it was like to grow
up having that intelligence so was sort
of two pieces of a puzzle there and
what's interesting Neil is that you
asked about the geopolitical climate
this all began with this character idea
it really it really was about as as
Larry said you know a potential hero's
journey of this kid towards a mentor and
the uh scientist need of someone the
pass's knowledge on to so all of the
geopolitical stuff and all of the ideas
about s nuclear war war and about uh
computerss really came out of research
uh Larry had a background in journalism
and I mine was in documentary films but
it really started with a character story
and which is I think one of the reasons
why it's still valid well give me give
me a three sentence review of the plot
uh so we've got a kid in high school who
accidentally hacks into NORAD yeah and
chck unintended consequences he he he
hacks into what he thinks as a game
company just wanting to play the coolest
new game and inadvertently hacks into
NORAD and runs a simulation which is
mistaken by nored as an actual missile
attack and it sort of becomes a story
there which unbeknownst to him or anyone
he's actually triggered an AI program
that was left over in the system by its
original Creator who cannot or that
cannot discern the difference between
reality and simulation and it unfolds
from there and the government pick him
up and they chase him a chase scene
helicopters you know and so and it's
Matthew brck who's a completely lovable
character and you're cheering from him
the entire time and and so so this so
the moral to the story then was what
don't have a
computer well I I
I think we stumbled upon something that
you know it was seems simplistic but it
it's sort of landed um if there is a
moral that you take away with that
there's certain games in which the only
winning move is not to play yes that was
the that was the the computers of wisdom
yeah and and it was Illustrated in a
game of tic-tac-toe but then sort of
generalized to the whole idea of
thermonuclear war
and um again it it sometimes you know
simple as best and I think we we were
able to kind of boiled down some complex
ideas to a simple enough premise that it
landed with people particularly in the
government as it turned out and how how
telling is it that all all this time
later
um the fact is that uh the AI knew
better than we
do okay that's number one and number two
the fact is that you're looking at right
now there seems to be a push towards
proliferation once again you know where
for many many years nuclear
proliferation nuclear for many years
it's been let's reduce let's reduce
let's get rid of let's let's move
towards a place where you know we make
this as minimal as possible and now
we're actually going in the opposite
direction well in many ways we're going
in the opposite direction right now yeah
yeah so so explain to me now what the
future of Life award is and what you
guys did to earn it well it's the most
prestigious award that no one has ever
heard of
okay says two recent recipients of the
award so so tell us about it well listen
it's put given by the future of Life
foundation and you know which is an
extraordinary group that you know
perhaps had one lapse in judgment which
is deciding to give it to two
screenwriters and it's really been given
to some extraordinary people including
Carl Sean I I think received it um for a
number I I think the idea is that it's
given to people who in retrospect have
made substantial contributions to sort
of the life of the planet or the quality
of life on the planet but were not
recognized at the time um and if you go
on the website there's some
extraordinary stories there including
actual Russian Comm missile Comm yeah
two refused yeah who refused to actually
to to to accept an order uh that was
ordering a launch um and and I think
that in this case with both us and with
dick Meyer who directed the day after
they're acknowledging the role of
narrative and popular culture in
spreading certain ideas and making them
accessible to people that now in
retrospect were sort of foundational so
what you're saying is the future of Life
reward has opened up its criteria to
recognize how
significant the effect of Storytelling
can be on the sentiment of a nation and
of the world Larry and I work Beyond
honored and surprised to be to be given
this award but listen you know complex
issues are difficult for people to grasp
and whether they're policy makers or the
public at large so there C certainly a
role of story in all of that you know
stories can be very powerful things
powerfully good powerfully bad you were
in a time of a lot of very false
narratives carrying a lot of weight so I
I think in this case the The Institute
was just trying to I don't know
acknowledge that when done right and
hopefully we did you know a story and
popular culture can be a way of
educating the public about we're all for
on Star Talk we're all for that because
we only I think people come for the pop
culture and humor but they stay for the
science right I mean the the attractors
or something that matters here otherwise
you'll have no influence on anybody all
right if if because they're not always
looking where you need them to look but
they will come to you if there's a pop
culture vessel uh that they can react
to We wanted to take a break to
congratulate the winners of this year's
future life award for reducing the risk
of new nuclear war through the power of
Storytelling the winners are Nicholas
Meyer Edward Hume and Brandon Stoddard
for their film the day after and
Lawrence Lasker and Walter F parks for
war games these filmmakers showed us how
storytelling can make a difference in
tackling the world's most pressing
challenges to learn more about future of
Life Institute and this year's winners
make sure to visit futureof life.org
when I think of this movie I wasn't
thinking this at the time because it was
just a movie and I was enjoying it but a
lot of themes are intersecting here so
you have the geopolitics of just Nation
against Nation you have the Cold War
nuclear arsenals you have Game Theory
you have computing power you have um
Power struggles and how does a military
force interact with a genius
who doesn't care about your your your
you know whether you're general or
Corporal or private they just know
what's true and then you have kids
caught up in the middle of it you genius
kids all of that was happening at once
and it Blended and became a coherent
story so I just want to congratulate the
two of you on that and I want to know
did the government actually learn
anything from you yeah we we screened
the movie for the President Reagan at
the time at Camp Davis
uh the opening weekend uh war games and
uh I had known the Reagan growing up so
I was in the because he was a he was a
movie star right so did you know him
through the California uh
connection he was he and Nancy were
friends of my parents my mom was a movie
star and uh they would come to our house
for Saturday night parties and uh my my
parents often showed First Run movies so
Saturday night movies was a theme uh and
the Reagans were always the first to
arrive s o'clock on the nose ding dong
and um so when uh when the movie was
coming out I I actually happened to run
into Nancy Reagan and I said I got this
movie coming out she said let's screen
it so we sent it to Camp David and that
following week reikan comes into the
meeting of his generals and says has
anyone seen this movie War Games you
know a kid could start World War II by
accident and it really got him thinking
and and his generals looked into it and
said oh yeah it could happen oh that's
comforting wait so when was the when was
the concept forgive me for not
remembering this the concept of mutual
assured destruction that was around that
time it had been around for years oh it
was around for years yeah okay and it's
not a very encouraging strategy I would
think but but it worked it works I mean
it's look what's happening without it um
in terms of world conflict but it it
ironically yeah as Larry said President
Reagan asked his generals about this
well there's a book that reported this
uh quite extensively and and and as it
turns out that a lot of even the current
cyber security laws that are on the
books in the US government sort of have
their foundation in that screening and
in what happened as a result of that um
it it it was a real sort of case study
in again as you're talking about Neil
how popular culture and story can
actually have an effect on policy
because it presents ideas in a way that
can be understood right and uh it
reminds me uh you know I I was uh on a
White House Commission studying the
future of Aerospace in the nation and in
the world and we visited an air show and
uh I had I I boarded one of these
military Air Force jets and this very
early in the internet I mean very early
where everything was dial up and things
and so I actually while I was there just
on this tour I hacked into the the the
the internet of that airplane and I saw
a couple of things so then I told them
about it and they said oh you can't do
that that's and they got angry and I
said wait dude
like what why would you leave why would
you leave this perfectly secure computer
terminal sitting here for me to
access my own computer didn't me to
compromise nuclear secrets no what I'm
saying is there is am I the enemy or did
I just do them a favor right right by
finding this weak spot on that plane and
so I don't think people knew how to
react to that kind of breach at the time
and so yeah you pick them up you try to
you know there's a chase scene there's a
you know you had all the right movie
elements to make it an exciting
storytelling that's funny you said that
because now the government actually
hires hackers yeah to and break into
things that's right they didn't offer me
a job at the time I'm sorry that that
was the premise of of our next movie
together called sneakers which are
really
about tiger teams that are hired to test
the security of of installations or
computer systems without the targets
knowing in order to uh reveal um you
know where the insecurities might be
where the vulnerabilities might be um
it's sometimes I think that you know did
did we do the world of disservice by
igniting all sorts of like hackers like
doing you know bad things or was this a
good thing to draw attention to the fact
that these systems are vulnerable and
the future of Life believes it's a good
thing well than I'm kind of thinking
that so so if he worries about now
security uh so you're saying Reagan
started thinking about cyber security at
that time that would have been an early
time to think that way correct
absolutely yeah the first law about
cyber
security on the books okay but it also
led to his uh trying to reduce uh the
threat of nuclear war with with the
Russians or the Soviets at the time you
know I think it's great though becc when
you think about it when I don't think
it's hyperbolic you know when you look
at the premise of this young kid doing
this I think that is it a good thing
that you know from a a pop culture
standpoint we started thinking that way
like what if you could break into you
know the government and you could could
you know get uh nuclear codes or start a
launch sure that's unlikely but just
thinking about it in that way I think
creates a better uh arena for security
and you look at it today we look at Ai
and I'm gonna say if it weren't for
James Cameron looking at AI in such a
way where you know you have a
singularity you have the machines take
over we wouldn't be thinking about AI
right now and
you're talking about Terminator
Terminator yes thank you I should have
said the movie right I was thinking of
the Titanic I remember when the AI was
dying on the board floating and Rose was
and Rose was saying no but yeah like
it's great that you get people to think
a certain way and then that becomes a
collective Consciousness because that's
who they vote for it's a it's a it
triggers an entire sequence of shift
zist shift which is important when you
need it I it it is funny when you think
back then there were sort of a Spate of
those movies ours being kind of the tail
wagging one of them which has to do with
digital technology run a muck right I I
think a Robocop is one actually a
favorite movie of mine um the first one
not the second one I presume yeah but
the first RoboCop's fantastic Terminator
you know in a funny way war games and I
think there is something about
demystifying all of that in other words
and becoming aware of that so that we
can actually deal with both the you know
the opportunities afforded by digital
technology or AI but also be very aware
of the uh potential dangers but we can't
nor can we forget the film Manhattan
Project all right which is also a high
school kid who invents an atomic bomb uh
and there was another one uh just sort
of in that in that genre so I'm
wondering if all that was partly
influenced by the John Hughes portfolio
which showed teenagers in high school as
the primary protagonist in every story
that unfolded with the adults as the
immature idiots working around I'm gonna
say that's it was just a marketing ploy
to get teens out to the movies no
all so after you screened it for
Reagan uh presumably others would in the
government would then have interests so
what was the what was the path that came
out of that screening Room in the White
House well other people wanted to see it
Reagan actually started telling the the
meeting of generals the the plot and
they all said please sir don't tell us
anymore we want to see the movie okay
and uh and then we and then the MGM
screened war games for congress oh okay
interesting I would have loved to go to
but we were doing our thing here in
California so I sent a friend of mine
there he and and what about this very
scary Prospect which Chuck has been
hinting at this whole conversation in
your movie the computer this AI
machine had power over the launch
codes so that it could make an
autonomous military decision about a
strike and that is a scary Prospect then
and
now probably more now yeah
and even before the a part of it um
Larry you you know the anog better we
actually while we're working on the on
the film there was a near war games like
scenario that took place where a
simulation was mistaken by command and
control as an actual attack yeah we were
we were actually in my apartment in
Santa Monica working on the script and
we were going is anyone could to believe
that this could happen and I turned on
the CBS Evening News and it was Walter
kite top of the news was for three
minutes yesterday the United States were
on a fullscale nuclear alert it turned
out it was a simulation tape that had
been left in a computer and it
completely freaked out the military
because they thought we were under
attack because the simulation was of a
full-scale Russian missile attack
fortunately someone caught it before we
voled our missiles back so then we
turned off the TV and said yeah people
will believe
it y let's keep keep going the script
Neil you brought up the Zeitgeist and
you're talking about why why kid
characters and um we had a really
interesting experience what was about
five or I forget how many years ago
where we uh we we were featured at a the
founders lunch they do at Google um to
have a talk conversation about about war
games because it turns out it was a
fairly important film for a lot of the
people who worked there um and at the
time looking back we realized we got all
sorts of things wrong but we got one big
essential thing right in that movie
which was that the uh and this is going
to your idea of the young characters
that that the world wouldn't be changed
by the US government policies or by IBM
or by m Bell but would be young people
either in their garages or in their
bedrooms using these extraordinary new
digital tools please tell everyone what
Mel is
the
telephone yeah yeah back when there was
one when there was one Telephone Company
AT&T was Mell okay but but but the point
is there is a David Lightman the
character our main character did have
his roots in being kind of a Punky you
know anti-establishment kid and we
certainly understood that you know that
in this case Innovation didn't come from
institutions didn't come from the
government it actually came from you
know the the ground up and from kids who
had a sort of intuitive understanding of
what these tools could be and so if you
look then over the next you know 5 10 15
20 years most of the innovation did come
from outside of big big companies yeah
in fact a year later was the Macintosh
was introduced you know and wired in a
garage so yeah the the timing of our
work on on beginning this screenplay was
was quite propitious um yes yes the
first thing we did when we got the deal
uh
the next week we I called SRI Stanford
Research Institute and talked to the
public information guy there told him a
little bit about what we're working on
and he said uh all right uh you want to
come up uh Tuesday and I said sure and
we went up there and he had like five
meetings set for us to meet smart people
who basically told us why we had come
and what questions to ask and all we had
to do was take notes and the the last
meeting was with a bunch of futurists
and one of them Peter Schwarz said uh
you know what Atari is up to yeah video
games he says okay well the military is
trying to Biggie back onto
them and I think that's where your kid
and your dying
scientist there it is and at the time
adults didn't really play video games
right it was the it was just just
getting going and and then when we
during research when we discovered that
home computers could hook up over phone
lines to bid computers we thought well
there's our movie I mean that was a
major Revelation that's how the kid
alone in his bedroom could get caught up
in in the world of high you know Tech
and Science and that third movie I was
saying in this in this kid genre was it
was your movie War Games there was
Manhattan Project a high school kid and
of course there was Real Genius which
were young college kids trying to
outsmart the military the US military so
given your life experience here and that
you're at least celebrated if not in the
day certainly later when people reflect
on how different the world might have
been had that movie not been made is
there some movie you think that needs to
be made today that isn't that we need
and even if there isn't some what movie
would you make today
okay I've been giving it some thoughts I
haven't come up with a definitive answer
yet but I'm going to keep trying you're
still you're still thinking okay oh yeah
you know here's the thing
about writing movies and it it really
goes back to the fact that we didn't set
out to do a movie about thuman nuclear
war or geopolitics or about the emerging
computer Revolution or AI as I said it
it was a movie about you know an idea
about two characters and luckily we had
the background in the time to kill to do
a lot of research so that we sort of had
an emotional Foundation yeah we were
open to what was going on in the world
correct and then we got some really good
informants too David Lewis who was a at
the UCLA Computer Club and he was a
hacker and he just took us through the
whole every step of what a hacker would
do and I could call him up and I'm
writing a scene and say well how do you
get a computer to play itself number of
players zero okay thanks David and then
and then Willis wear who was at the Rand
Corporation was our advisor on sort of
the the computer systems and he had
actually designed the computer system at
NORAD and when we
said unlike some experts who tell you
why you can't do whatever you want to do
Willis would say what do you need we say
well we need the kid to be able to
access you know a top secret computer
and he says yeah you could do it he says
they tell you those computers are
absolutely Ely Standalone
isolated
everyone everyone wants if they
want to work from home on the weekend
they set up a little back
door back door it's a back door all the
way and the programmer of the software
can leave a back door without telling
anybody else right yes absolutely yeah
but just to go back to C's question so
I don't think you can ever decide I'm G
to make a movie about you know a concept
I mean I or or it'll just turn out to be
sort of I don't know rigid butun yeah
yeah yes but we are at a moment in terms
of AI that we're pretty much depending
on tropes of the last 20 years we
brought up Jim Cameron's movies Etc and
it's a much more complex issue than that
yes and I wonder if there's a way to go
after that idea um with a narrative um
as you could imagine Larry and I over
the years have been brought more than
our share of ideas for war game sequels
but in a funny way the idea that there
would be a uh you know an intelligent
program our Joshua program that's been
alive out there in the Cyber in
cyberspace Joshua was the name of the
program for those who remember this
corre that's been out there learning and
navigating the cyberspace as as the
distin between the virtual world and the
physical world becomes less and less
there is probably a good story to be
told there and we'll just if you make
the sequel you got to bring Matthew brck
back as the general
ah that would be good that's that's an
implicit endorsement right a good one
Neil yeah not that any of you all asked
but I served on a board of the Pentagon
uh a the Pentagon Innovation board where
we thought deeply about what what role
emerging Technologies Computing and
otherwise would or should play in
National Security and we tackled AI in a
statement in a report where we said AI
is fine for identifying targets and all
this sort of thing but there must be a
human in a loop if that decision
requires a kill you cannot have ai
autonomously
decide that an attack should occur
thatony decide that an attack will occur
you have to have a human being in there
and this is a sort of ethos that is now
part of the military as we go forward
trying to figure out how AI fits into
our lives so in in the case of war games
that was not the
case war that was yes the premise of War
games it was not written that way it was
like Joshua could do this all by itself
correct yeah the beginning of the movie
is the premise is that the missile
commanders fail the test they don't want
to turn the keys to to kill 100 million
people until they get someone on the
phone to tell them and uh so they decide
well this we can't do this let's get rid
of the humans and just put the machines
in control right right I've forgotten
that that was a bit of tension at the
beginning there yes yes very good very
good well gentlemen this has been a
delight to have you on uh we're
continuing this
program on the future of Life award uh
because coming up uh we're gonna have
Nicholas Meer who's a who directed the
TV film the day after which was seen by
essentially every single American when
it aired and uh we'll pick up that
conversation uh with him when we return
again guys thanks for being on Star Talk
thanks so much sure thank
you Chuck continuing with this future of
Life award what intrigues me is that
this is a set of awards that this year
went to the power of Storytelling yes to
affect change rather than people who
might have themselves had access to the
button and didn't push it thereby sort
of saving the world this is there are
other ways to save the world and we
cannot undervalue the power of of a good
story told well told with impact emotion
and that brings us right to the director
of the movie The Day After I remember
this movie I was like Fully Alive and
cognizant when this movie came out in
1983 we have with us the director of
that movie Nicholas Meyer Nicholas
welcome to Star Talk hi thanks for
inviting me you're not only a
screenwriter director author you you're
deep into the Star Trek you Universe
is's a universe or world what should I
there's like the Marvel un work okay
Universe works by the way that's how I
know him oh no okay uh you director of
The Wrath of KH co-writer of the the
Voyage Home was that save the whales
that was the save the whales one right
yeah my my best line in that is what is
exact change as they get kicked off the
bus uh and so uh in in Star Trek
Discovery you're all in Trek universe so
you you you've got the right Street
Credit here for our audience and and in
there among there before that you were
director of the day after not only are
you in the Star Trek fandom creating
content for that Universe uh you're also
writing Sherlock Holmes oh my gosh so a
year ago the return of the Pharaoh and
coming up Sherlock Holmes and the
telegram from hell so you're a busy guy
a busy guy congratulations on it all and
the world is a better place and dare I
say safer place for you being in it oh
my mother thanks you and I thank
you yeah so the day after is like it's
the day after total thermonuclear
exchange with the Soviet Union and it's
a movie about that it aired on ABC it
was a TV movie aired on
ABC all everybody what everybody was
talking about this the day after day
after almost the entire country
watched one one thing at one time one
thing at one time which doesn't happen
anymore that doesn't happen anymore and
and and a 100 million people I'm one of
those 100 million so so Nicholas can you
just remind us of the geopolitical
climate in 1983 Reagan was President
gorbachov was uh head of the the party
in I think is that right in the Soviet
Soviet Union yes he was the good old
days well actually excuse me he was not
uh his predecessor was the very aged
Yuri andropov Yuri andropov okay and uh
this was I at the time characterized as
the absolute
lowo in US Soviet relations there's no
more Soviet Union but us Russia
relations are now at a as as bad or
probably worse Point than they were in
1983 but Yuri
andropov uh
believed that Ronald Reagan was prepared
to push the button at any moment and he
wasn't far wrong Ronald Reagan came to
power believing in a winnable nuclear
war as if if you watch um drct Strange
Love uh George C Scott as general Buck
turgidson said says to uh the president
played by Peter sers Mr President I'm
not saying we're not going to get our
hair musk but I'm telling you 10 20
million dead tops and it was that sort
of thinking that prevailed at the time
that the movie came
out wow and we were we were all everyone
was basically held hostage to this
nuclear arms race and so so you you have
many Tal in this space as screenwriter
director and author um how did you land
the director's role for the day after
well I certainly was nobody's first
choice I believe okay okay you're you're
our first choice you are you are our
first choice of course well but I was
the I believe I was the third director
to be asked I think it's important to
establish the great Paradox with which
we are dealing and have been dealing
since
1945 and the explosion of atom bombs
overa you
bet the ability to annihilate ourselves
is
arguably possibly along with climate
change the most important question that
has ever faced the human race and by
extension of all of planet Earth and yet
and here's the paradox
it is so
disturbing that nobody can bear to think
about
it we don't want to talk about it in the
words of George Bush we say go shopping
so what we we do is we pretend that this
damoclean sword which is dangling by an
Ever fraying cord over our heads doesn't
exist but as Daniel Ellsberg
said uh hope is not a strategy
luck luck is not a strategy and I have
to say that at the time I was the third
director to be offered this I didn't
want to think about nuclear war either I
directed a couple of hit
movies I'd been nominated for an Academy
Award who wanted to do this but in fact
I was being
psychoanalyzed at the time I was lying
on the couch
and trying to talk my way out of doing
this when my analyst who never
spoke said well I think this is where we
find out who you really are o
Checkmate that's how that's how I wound
up doing the movie not not because I'm a
professional doood gooder or altruist
and so uh here's my memory of the plot
and tuned it up if I get it wrong so it
follows a family or some some some uh or
town in Kansas where we have a higher
concentration of nuclear of silos and in
any first exchange what I do know is you
want to First Take out the other
person's nukes before you start going
after the cities or any other targets
and so Kansas became a hot bed for the
first arrival of these nuclear weapons
and they do hit and they do go off and
you watch people attempting to survive
this into the next day that was what I
remember well basically Kansas was
lawence Kansas was picked simply because
it's the geographical center of the
continental United
States the fact that we have these
missile silos all over the United States
they're all over um is is part of the
Great
Folly uh of our policy and politics
because it simply makes sitting targets
for for every place you have a missile
is a target whereas as Daniel ellberg
so um precisely pointed out we can
defend ourselves with Polaris submarines
which are much harder to locate than
pinning these targets all over the place
and and accidents happen in these
targets you may remember some years ago
in AR saw a monkey runch fell down a
missile silo un loo the fuel leak that
almost precipitated uh the annihilation
of all of Arkansas so and there have
been a lot of nuclear accidents many wow
literal monkey is it a literal monkey
wrench yes what Ed Hume who wrote the
screenplay did was he simply wrote about
a lot of regular people not just one
family but different people doing
different things things going to college
getting married on and on and on some
people uh who worked in the military who
go down in those silos among them in
other words people like us doing what we
do and they all get nuked that's the
movie that's the I mean to laugh but but
but that's the but but I remember it was
a it was an event it was a television
event and I also distinctly remember
that after the film there was a panel of
experts which included Carl Sean uh I
think Henry Kissinger La William JRA yes
some of the deep deep thinkers of the
day to analyze what had just happened
and so let me ask you this the future of
Life award goes to people who played
some pivotal role in Saving All of
humanity and and most people don't even
know it so it's a way to tease out of
the history of human conduct those
people who mattered greatly so so if
this movie was just a movie and people
saw it and went about their
way you wouldn't be recognized 40 years
later it's just a movie so how did this
end up mattering geopolitically
afterwards Ronald Reagan as I said came
to power believing in a winnable nuclear
war the day after I think was
responsible I I think I can say this
because I think Reagan said it for
starters in his Memoir and Edmund
moris uh also said it um he was Reagan's
official biographer and when Ronald
Reagan saw the
movie
and I think for a a lot of people you
know when when when Stalin once said you
know when a child falls down a well
that's a tragedy but when Millions die
that's statistics Mr President I'm not
saying we're not going to get our hair
musked we're just talking abstraction at
this point but when you see those
missiles take off and and we've all been
raised on a hundred years of Hollywood
Happy Endings right and suddenly there
was and he flipped
out uh and he's a Hollywood guy he's a
Hollywood guy so this is
especially not even I I don't even think
that's the main point there was a
general on Castro's staff who said that
the Cuban Missile Crisis had not been
real to him till he saw the
movie I think it's about Imagining the
unimaginable doesn't matter if you're a
Hollywood actor or or not he yes he may
have been more naive he told Helen
calicot that the missiles could be
recalled and she said Mr President they
can't be recalled he didn't know that um
anyway what happened was this on the job
training that's
all he wound up changing his mind and
when gorb after he after he saw the film
yes I don't you know I don't I think
Edmund Mars who was in The White House
who was his official biographer uh and I
also got to know Mars because he wrote
the rise of Theodore Roosevelt which I
wrote as a screenplay for Martin scorsi
at one point and he told me he lived in
the White House for three years and he
said the only time he ever saw Reagan
lose it was after he saw the movie wow
and ultimately what happened
was uh Yuri andropov uh died and and
gorbachov took over and there was glos
and there was perista and Reagan went to
regui to meet with gorbachov and
ultimately signed the intermediate
Missile Range treaty with him he was on
his way to signing off on a lot more um
but he wouldn't give up his uh Strategic
Defense Initiative which we call Star
Wars um and then he
um so that that and Daniel ellberg
explained to me and ellsburg had been
nuclear war planner that the treaty that
resulted between Reagan and gorbachov in
Iceland which The Fearless Grabber
in Chief has now walked out of was the
only treaty that ever resulted in the
physical
dismantling of nuclear weapons so that's
my little contribution to world history
I'm I'm interested to know how that that
how it came to Reagan that that you guys
as a production say Hey you know you
should take a look at this or did screen
this at the White House or did his
advisers say my God or was it just the
sheer magnitude of the event itself the
fact that more than half the country it
watches one television event all
together and then what kind of what kind
of public reaction did that have
something to do with maybe him Chuck a
good point because often a politician in
a democracy in a republic has to be
responsive to what the public thinks
right they can't be opposite what their
electorate says otherwise you don't get
reelected so so unless unless you have
Jerry mandering with that's a whole
another show Let Me Explain as best I
can basically the secret of the film's
success in my opinion but I I think I
can sort of back it up
was the controversy that accompanied it
the very idea everybody at ABC the
network that was making the movie hated
the movie hated the idea of it couldn't
stand it they knew they were going to
lose all their sponsors this is not what
was shown on American network television
they did the time flying they did The
Flying Nun they did laughing but their
main business is to sell products
it's it's it's to advertise and they
knew this wasn't going to happen they
were going to lose a bucket on this one
man wanted this movie made his name was
Brandon Stoddard if you're giving prizes
he's not alive but he should get the
prize because he insisted despite death
threats and all he had to threaten to
resign to get this movie on the air this
is what he wanted he's the guy who did
Roots and he was looking to a followup
for roots and the controver
Y and the nuclear freeze movement got
Reagan's attention got the White House's
attention and before he saw the movie
Ronald Reagan regarded the movie as a
threat we were offered defense
department cooperation you can have
missiles you can have tanks you can have
helicopters whatever you want just make
sure that the Russians started the war
we told them to off so we had to sort of
do it in our own way
without that but this was on Reagan's
radar and the more Phillis Schley and
Bill Buckley went running up and down
the country like Chicken Little
insisting that the sky was falling if
this movie got on the air the more the
White House in the country got drawn
into what is it why can't I watch it
blah blah blah blah blah and that's
that's why 100 million people watched it
in one night incidentally there's a
documentary about the making of this
movie now which is called uh television
event and I believe television event is
available on YouTube and I must also
tell you because I just got this in the
mail oh that this is coming out November
15th tell us the title for those who are
only listening it's called apocalypse
television how the day after helped end
the Cold War sweet by David Craig um
just got it in the mail this morning it
it comes out on the 15th and I I read it
course 15th of November 2023 immediately
went to the index to see how I turned
out and yeah I come off like a jerk half
the time and the rest of the time I come
out okay so I figure whatever um on
balance but but there are other
apocalyptic uh moments for for example
uh Netflix had the film that um uh don't
look up although that was comedic but
their their apocalyptic films are are
are important genre oh my gosh right
yeah but I think there the difference
there's a
certain now that we have great special
effects it's kind of fun to see New York
City inundated by water and and and and
and and sort of the effects take over my
point is that I as a director figuring
out about this movie while I was making
it I realized that I didn't want to make
a really good piece of Cinema because I
realized that if the
movie had great acting and great
cinematography and a catchy theme song
Blah Blah nobody was GNA talk about the
subject we would do anything not to talk
about the subject
gas what I remember most is that I
didn't recognize any of the actors well
we didn't want a lot of boldface names
you you that's you succeeded at that and
I I had there was nothing else I could
pay attention to but the storyline that
that's kudos to kudos to your whole
concept I wanted to make a
movie like a public service announcement
if you have a nuclear war this is what
it's going to look like on a good day we
didn't show nuclear winter because we
didn't know about it but we did show the
electromagnetic
pulse because we did know about that um
and but I just wanted it
to and I started out thinking oh yes
right I could unseat Ronald Reagan or
some grandiose like that and then I
realized no forget all that just show
them what it's going to be like and we
couldn't make it too terrible because
people would reach for the C clicker and
change the channnel to something else so
it was a tight RPP act but I you know
again I didn't want music in the movie
so there's very little music in the
movie I didn't want to be accused of
goosing anybody's emotions or
editorializing just the facts ma'am so
we're running short on time a quick
question here uh so remind me who
launched missiles first if you ignored
the dod's request to not show
um America as a first strike I I don't
remember what started it nobody know
nobody knows we never showed it oh okay
that was the that was the whole point of
the movie was not to show who who
started it and by the
way when we get nuked yeah no one will
care no one will know no one will know
and no and no one nobody's going to be
afterwards going who did this you know
because it's just not going to happen
because it'll be so incredibly
devastating we'll be sitting here
talking and then we'll be gone and not a
question of who started it right it
won't it won't matter um so well all
right so Nicholas give me give me
something positive to think about going
forward we have to get past the Paradox
of not wanting to think about this it's
not enough to you know contribute to
some charity online send in you know $10
and hope for the best luck is not a
strategy
hope is not a strategy you have to get
out in the streets and demand change and
you have to do it in astronomical
numbers in order to make things happen
this is this is a call to action is you
bet going on and and and and there's not
a lot of uh there's not a lot of time
yeah well it's interesting you say that
because what what the thing that is most
disturbing about this issue right now is
that you have talk when um and saber
rattling uh surrounding limited strike
capabilities or oh yeah this is a big
thing that's being bandied about right
now and I I don't know how you feel
about that but um I could guess I could
venture to
guess the thing the thing that's really
dumb about nuclear weapons is that they
can never be used and yet we we keep on
building more and more of them
um you're not going to get the
toothpaste back in the tube once this
starts it won't stop well that's that's
a a a call to action a call for peace a
call for sanity I guess it's a call for
sanity yes There It Is Well Nicholas
first congratulations on this award
thank you we need more people to keep
the world safe whether they household
names are not and I'm delighted that we
could at least help in our little way to
bring attention to this 40th anniversary
I'm extremely grateful and very honored
excellent all right all right Nicholas I
Chuck always good to have you man always
a pleasure so this has been Star Talk
Neil degrass Tyson here you're a
personal astrophysicist and we' had a
celebration of the future of Life award
uh check it out futureof life.org online
as always keep looking
up
[Music]
oh